feeding a martian population
necessitates Innovative agricultural
practices traditional farming is
impossible in the Martian soil so we've
turned to Hydroponics and aeroponics
these soilless farming methods allow us
to grow crops and nutrient-rich Water
Solutions using minimal space and
resources imagine rows of vibrant green
vegetables flourishing in a martian
Greenhouse genetic modification plays a
crucial role in adapting Earth crops to
the Martian environment scientists have
developed genetically modified crops
that can tolerate the lower gravity
higher radiation levels and the specific
composition of the Martian soil these
GMOs are essential for ensuring food
Security on Mars we are pushing the
boundaries of Agricultural Science to
create a sustainable food supply Beyond
plant-based Foods